FOR MORE WE'RE JOINED BY SENIOR
FERGUSON CORRESPONDENT JESSICA
WILLIAMS. SHE'S
LIVE IN MISSOURI.
>> HI.
>> Jon: JESSICA, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: HOW ARE YOU, JESSICA?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE AT
THE FERGUSON POLICE STATION.
>> OH, I AM, JON.
THAT'S THE POLICE STATION RIGHT
BEHIND ME.
PRETTY SWEET, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLY REGAL.
I DIDN'T EXPECT A SMALL-TOWN
PRECINCT TO BE MORE OPULENT THAN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> YEAH, JON, AND LIKE THE WHITE
HOUSE, IT WAS ALSO BUILT BY
BLACK PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
BOOM!
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE, HUH, JESSICA?
>> YUP.
( BLEEP ) THESE PEOPLE.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT. NOW, JESSICA IN
THE WAKE OF THE D.O.J. REPORT,
DO YOU THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
REFORMS NOW THAT WE DIDN'T --
YEAH --
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS,
IT IS TOO EARLY TO SAY,
JON --
>> I'M SORRY, WHAT'S THAT ON
YOUR-- WHAT'S THAT ON YOUR
SHIRT?
>> WHAT?
>> Jon: ON YOUR --
>> DAMN IT'S A CITATION FOR
EXCEEDING THE HEIGHT LIMIT FOR
SIDEWALK USE.
THAT'S A $50 FINE.
>> Jon: WOW, THAT'S A REAL
OFFENSE AND THEY GOT YOU QUICK.
>> WOW, I BETTER PAY THIS RIGHT
NOW.
THIS FINE DOUBLES IN 10 MINUTES.
>> Jon: WOW, FERGUSON POLICE,
FERGUSON POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE
INCREDIBLY EFFICIENT,
ALTHOUGH YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THE COPS WOULD NOW GO
ELECTRONIC, MAYBE HAVE SOME
KIND OF AN EZ-PASS SYSTEM OR
SOMETHING FOR THESE TYPES OF
CITATIONS.
BUT JESSICA, ARE YOU SUGGESTING
THAT EVEN AFTER THE REVELATIONS
IT'S BUSINESS AS USUAL AT THE
FERGUSON P.D.?
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
JON.
>> Jon: JESUS JESSICA, WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> OH ( BLEEP )!
UH LET'S SEE -- TRESPASSING.
WE GOT ANOTHER ONE FOR
JAY-STANDING.
FOR SODOMY?
WHAT THE ( BLEEP )!
OH YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS ONE IS
FOR WITH POSSESSION WITH
INTENT-- OH, LOOK AND
THIS ONE CAME WITH A
DIME BAG STAPLED TO IT.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M JUST GONNA SAVE THAT ONE FOR
LATER.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
JESSICA, ARE WE GOING TO SEE
MORE PROTESTS THEN IN FERGUSON?
>> HELL YEAH, BUT THIS TIME
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT THIS
INJUSTICE IN TERMS WHITE AMERICA
CAN UNDERSTAND.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN ANGRY OLD
WHITE PEOPLE STARTED THE TEA
PARTY?
>> Jon, OF COURSE, I REMEMBER
THAT.
>> WELL, BLACK PEOPLE ARE
STARTING THE F.E.A. PARTY.
THEY'RE FINED ENOUGH ALREADY.
NO MORE TAXATION WITHOUT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION.
HANDS UP, DON'T
LOOT OUR SAVINGS.
>> Jon: I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THERE.
BLACK FIVES MATTER, JON!
>> Jon: BLACK FIVES DO
MATTER.
>> HEY, JESSICA.
>> OH HEY, JASON.
>> HOW'S IT GOING?
>> EXCUSE ME, SIR, SIR!
>> WHAT?
>> IS THAT WOMAN BOTHERING YOU?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THIS
BLACK ONE HERE?
NO, SHE'S COOL. BYE. OH, YOU'VE
GOT MY, YOU'VE GOT MY --
>> Jon: JESSICA, I THINK YOU
NEED TO GET OUT OF FERGUSON
RIGHT NOW, JESSICA.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I CAN'T, JON.
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T PAY THAT FINE
FROM FIVE MINUTES AGO AND NOW
I'VE BEEN BOOTED.
>> Jon: OH, FOR GOD'S SAKES.